du jasmin
des herbes sauvages
de l'oranger
j'adorerais créer mon parfum un parfum
épicurieux pour tous ceux qui aiment
transmettre
pour tous ceux qui aiment apprendre
mais aussi pour tous les autres
le savoir a enfin son parfum
érudit byepicurieux
[Musique]
sympa non bon c'est un peu compliqué
mais je vais quand même vous donner la
recette
[Musique]
sur le podium des cadeaux les plus
offerts pour la fête des mères le parfum
arrive sur la deuxième marche derrière
les fleurs mais avant une invitation au
resto et ce n'est pas la seule occasion
pour laquelle on achète un parfum en
France il se vantent en moyenne plus de
150 000 flacons de parfum par jour ça
fait plus d'un par seconde la plupart
des parfums de grandeur qui sont
fabriqués sur la Côte d'Azur à Grasse
dans cette petite ville de
l'arrière-pays niçois ont créé et on
fabrique aussi toutes sortes de senteurs
qui embaume notre quotidien et on
fabrique des parfums pour tout pour la
litière du chat l'eau du fer à repasser
l'odeur des viennoiseries on reproduit
même
[Musique]
l'odeur du gazon fraîchement coupé pour
fabriquer un parfum on commence d'abord
par capturer les odeurs produites par
les fleurs et on ne les attrape pas au
vol ces substances se concentrent bien
souvent
dans les pétales c'est le cas pour les
roses et se présente sous la forme de
molécules très volatiles au passage une
molécule c'est une combinaison d'atomes
des grains de matière de carbone de
l'hydrogène de l'oxygène tout ça c'est
de la matière invisible évidemment pour
fabriquer un parfum il faut donc
extraire ces molécules un peu comme on
extrait du fer de la roche alors il
existe plusieurs méthodes pour y
parvenir l'une des plus répandues et
l'extraction par solvant c'est un
processus complexe qui est en temps
normal prend beaucoup de temps du coup
j'ai un peu simplifié vous n'avez pas
que ça à faire première étape cueillir
des fleurs et détacher les pétales ça
c'est à la portée de tout le monde
maintenant un peu de chimie on dépose
les pétales dans une cuve bon la mienne
est un peu petite dans la réalité
entraide jusqu'à 100 kg de pétales de
roses deuxième étape on verse de l'exane
il s'agit d'un solvant les molécules
odorantes vont s'y dissoudre en fait
l'examen a une très grande affinité avec
les molécules odorantes les deux se lit
facilement ensuite il faut récupérer les
molécules odorantes pour cela on chauffe
sous l'effet de la chaleur l'examen
s'évapore et à l'arrivée il ne reste
plus qu'une sorte de matière visqueuse
on dirait un peu de la cire ou du savon
noir c'est ce qu'on appelle la concrète
[Musique]
ça sent déjà très bon normal car la
concrète contient toutes les molécules
odorantes qui étaient présentes dans les
pétales bon il y a aussi pas mal de
corps gras du coup le travail n'est pas
terminé il faut maintenant laver la
concrète pour la débarrasser des corps
gras et des impuretés on utilise de
l'alcool et une fois l'alcool évaporez
on obtient ce que l'on appelle
l'absolu vous en avez déjà entendu
parler non c'est un liquide parfumé
ultra concentré
un peu fort quand même les rendements de
cette substance sont très faibles pour
produire 1 kg d'absolu de rose par
exemple il faut 800 kg de fleurs ça vaut
une fortune 1 kg d'absolu à partir de
rose cultivées à Grasse peut coûter plus
de 10000 euros maintenant qu'il soit
réservé aux marques de luxe c'est à
partir de ce produit que les fameux nez
qui travaillent pour les grands
parfumeurs composent leurs assemblages
et créer des parfums le nez est au
parfum ce qu'un œnologue est au vin il
doit assembler différentes fragrances
comme un monologue assemble différencée
pages ou millésime on ne compte pas plus
de 500 nez dans le monde dont une
centaine en France pour composer un
parfum ils ont alors disposition des
extraits de plantes de fleurs de fruits
de bois de racine de graines de feuilles
la palette olfactive de la parfumerie
est immense et ils peuvent combiner
jusqu'à une trentaine d'odeurs et
maintenant comment fonctionne notre
odorat pourquoi certaines odeurs ne
plaisent et d'autres avez-vous déjà
senti l'odeur du gaz dans votre cuisine
ce n'est pas très agréable et bien c'est
fait exprès c'est odeur souffrait a été
ajoutée au gaz qui lui n'a pas d'odeur
le but c'est de détecter au plus vite
les fuites car les mauvaises odeurs nous
interpellent autant que les bonnes le
mécanisme de détection est le même les
molécules odorantes pénètrent dans la
cavité nasale puis au fond de cette
qualité elle se fixe sur des récepteurs
spécifiques chez l'humain il y a environ
5 millions de récepteurs olfactifs en
comparaison les chiens en ont 220
millions chaque récepteur ne peut
détecter qu'un type de molécule quand
une de ces substances se lit un
récepteur elle active le neurones qui le
prolonge et fait remonter l'information
jusqu'au cerveau qui l'interprète comme
une odeur particulière en général les
odeurs que nous sentons autour de nous
sont composés d'une multitude de
molécules odorantes qui activent donc de
nombreux récepteurs vous imaginez alors
le nombre de combinaisons possibles et
donc le nombre d'odeurs que nous pouvons
sentir revenons au gaz la combinaison
donnée par son odeur provoque une
sensation de dégoût ces effluves
souffrés ne sont pas agréables on dirait
de l’œuf pourri dans notre cerveau c'est
todeurs de soufre est rangé parmi les
mauvaises pourquoi et bien parce que
c'est l'odeur que dégage un aliment
décomposition et qu'un aliment qui
dégage une telle odeur s'il était ingéré
pourrait provoquer une intoxication avec
le temps notre cerveau a associé cette
odeur à d'autres dangers au risque
d'explosion ou d'asphyxie au contraire
les effluves d'un gâteau au chocolat qui
sort du four peut vite nous mettre l'eau
à la bouche elles activent le circuit de
la récompense elle provoque la
libération de dopamine une molécule
associée au plaisir et surtout à l'envie
de croquer dedans mais tout le monde n'a
pas la même définition de ce qu'est une
bonne odeur prenons l'exemple du
camembert son odeur est apprécié d'un
grand nombre de Français personnellement
j'adore mais pour beaucoup d'étrangers
cette odeur est répugnante
l'apprentissage joue donc un rôle
important dans nos perceptions on l'a vu
avec le soufre à force d'expérience on
se met à aimer ou à détester telle ou
telle odeur mais cela peut aussi être dû
à la génétique car tout le monde ne
dispose pas des mêmes capteurs tenez la
plupart des français par exemple sont
sensibles à l'andro sténone une hormone
odorante produite par le port notamment
si la viande de porc en est imprégnée ça
va les dégoûter mais les personnes qui
ne possèdent pas le récepteur sensible à
cette hormone ne sont pas dérangés bref
bonne ou mauvaise une odeur c'est avant
tout une question d'apprentissage mais
aussi de génétique il n'y a pas que
l'odeur qui peut déranger dans un parfum
[Musique]
son prix aussi le jus contenu dans le
flacon ne représente pourtant qu'entre 5
et 10% du prix
le flacon entre 10 et 15%, les 80%
restants c'est du marketing et un peu de
distribution alors qu'au départ
lorsqu'il a été inventé ce n'est ni un
objet commercial ni un moyen de masquer
les odeurs corporelles le parfum servait
à communiquer avec les dieux son
histoire débute il y a 4000 ans à cette
époque les Égyptiens se mettent à brûler
des aromates ou de la résine pour entrer
en relation avec leur dieu en effet
cette fumée qui monte et vanessante
semble de nature à atteindre les dieux
qui eux aussi sont impalpables et
immatériels cette pratique est à
l'origine du mot parfum père foumoum en
latin qui signifie par la fumée mais
bien vite son utilisation évolue les
cordes et défunts sont embaumés avec des
aromates les statues des divinités sont
frottées avec des huiles sacrées
parfumées enfin les hommes et les femmes
commencent à s'en mettre sur la peau par
la suite les Grecs et les Romains
l'adoptent à leur tour ils indissociable
de la toilette et s'invite dans les
bains publics un terrible évènement va
propulser les parfums sur le devant de
la scène au 14e siècle la peste noire
dévastent l'Europe et la peur de l'eau
s'installe on sait alors de se laver au
prétexte que l'eau augmenterait les
risques d'infection en ouvrant les
portes de la peau permettant ainsi au
miasme de pénétrer dans les corps du
jour au lendemain les bains sont
proscrits alors pour camoufler les
mauvaises odeurs des corps mal lavés et
bien on utilise du parfum on en met
partout sur les vêtements sur les objets
du quotidien partout donc sur la peau
plus tard à Versailles on asperge les
mouchoirs les éventails les perruques
mais aussi les boiseries on raconte même
que Louis XIV faisait parfumer les
fontaines de Versailles heureusement à
partir du XVIIIe siècle l'air redevient
respirable car on redécouvre l’hygiène
peu à peu les parfums se font moins
capiteux leur est alors au raffinement
et ça dure toujours
j'aime bien celui-ci voilà il ne me
reste plus qu'à vous conseiller la
lecture de ce bouquin le parfum de
Patrick süskin l'histoire de
Jean-Baptiste Grenouille un parfumeur un
peu particulier à l'origine le bouquin
était sous-titré l'histoire d'un
meurtrier je ne vous en dis pas plus
vous me direz en commentaire ce que vous
en pensez allez bonne fin de journée
excellente semaine et à dimanche
prochain chers épicurieuses et
épicurieux
[Applaudissements]